i think the things we need to talk about
it's not necessarily things we're not
talking about i just think we're talking
about things in the complete opposite
way we should be talking about them like
i think it's important to talk about
things like racism in society it's
important to talk about whether or not
there are
environmental components to behavioral
differences between sexes or
or whatever species you're talking about
but we just need to
have a more sober conversation where we
don't leave
some explanations off the table before
the conversation even begins
you can't talk about things like any
sort of cultural inertia that any
population might have
regardless of where it's coming from in
the world like we can't talk about any
of
those sort of factors like any cultural
factors whatsoever that could be
predictive of differential group
outcomes like that's just off the table
you can't talk about those
at all
colin flipping right in the building how
are you doing man
i'm doing well it's a good intro
yeah like that's the best intro i've had
so far what can you say
when i'm away i'm on holiday i'm just in
a jovial mood you know just ready to
discuss some evolutionary biology
i'm down let's do it i love it so what's
the most undiscussed topic
in evolutionary biology which you think
should be talked about more
so right out of the gates there um yeah
there's very limited foreplay
in this show colin it's kind of straight
in
yeah i mean so there's there's these
bigger overarching questions about
just like human evolution um
how we evolve certain complex traits
behaviorally and otherwise
but i'd say it's really gonna depend who
you ask on some of these
issues some people think that we can
explain all the diversity of life and
all the behavior
with current models of evolutionary
thinking
just gradualism you know mutation
selection
and then you have some people like i've
heard people like brett weinstein for
instance he's
he thinks there's like a missing
component that you know we need to have
some
sort of paradigm shift and we need
something to explain things like
peacock's tales and
uh why there's so much diversity in the
tropics and
things like that and i'm sort of in the
camp that we've we've figured out like
the main
big trends and like how at least in
principle how these things could have
arisen
uh i haven't been totally convinced that
there's
any massive discoveries to be made in
terms of you know they're just gonna
like
completely change the way we think about
evolutionary biology
um i think from this point forward it's
gonna be more like
tweaking bits and i'm sure i mean there
can be some substantial insight we might
gain from areas but
um yeah i think i think it's going to be
largely applying the same principles of
you know darwinian natural neutral
selection to to
sort of things that we already kind of
know about then you can also go the
other route and say
well the important things to learn about
are things that we
we kind of already know but we're not
really allowed to say maybe or
to some degree because there's sort of a
social taboo against things and i think
that's probably more threatening to
evolutionary biology in the short term
and maybe even long term depending on
you know how long sort of these cultural
norms last that won't let people
you know speak freely about certain
controversial topics or something
uh or are they only even worse they only
allow sort of
one side the the side that is
sort of uh aligns more with our morality
or something that they only allow that
side really to get published because
it's just
they they they'll go through review a
lot faster because they they kind of
are leaning towards all the
preconceptions and views that reviewers
might already have or something so then
you get like a biased literature
that's not really reflective of reality
but sort of reflective of
what we'd kind of like to be true in a
sense so
uh yeah that's sort of my overarching
take on sort of evolution
at the moment got you what's the
bifurcating that you're talking about
between
brett's approach and uh
your conception of how evolutions worked
you know it's not entirely clear because
he hasn't fully fleshed out
the things he's he's proposing um is it
commonly held
one area not in my experience
no not i mean in my time in academia i
hadn't heard
sort of this types of critiques that
he's been proposing
um but it's also i'm not exactly sure
with the type of critiques he is
proposing because
um and i do get a little frustrated from
sometimes he'll
he'll post things that are sort of these
uh
he'll say something that you know
evolution is i don't want to misquote
him but this is sort of
paraphrasing um you know in a crisis we
haven't really
made any big discoveries lately
um and he kind of in a way if you
there's a way to read them where he
seems to be like tipping his hat
towards like the intelligent design
people or something even though that's
not what he's really doing
but whenever i've sort of pressed him to
go into more detail he doesn't really go
into
crazy detail about uh what exactly he's
proposing he's
he's proposed certain things like um
these different behavioral
uh types that he called like explorer
modes that explains maybe how
how individuals can find new habitat uh
even though them exploring new habitat
wouldn't be
selected at like an individual level um
he might have a similar thing that
applies to just morphological traits and
sort of a
bounded mutations and things like that
and these are all ideas that
i'm totally open to it's just i haven't
heard them fleshed out in a way
that makes me think like there's there's
something there that's
that's really missing that i need to i
need to find out what this is
i like to have a podcast with him at
some point and just have him lay it all
out and him and heather are writing a
book and maybe he'll go they'll go in
more on this
and he's also suggested because he got
pushed back from people like michael
shermer too that was
saying like you know what are you saying
and also jerry coyne who's one of the
most
i guess prominent evolutionary
biologists sort of called them out in a
big
blog post that was just like what the
hell is going on like what are you what
are you talking about
and the response wasn't it wasn't
substantial it was just saying like
maybe i'll write a book on this and then
we can
move from there and so i was like that's
fine uh he doesn't tend to want to go
the
the publishing and academic journals
route because he
thinks there's sort of a gated
institutional narrative and they're
they're gonna
suppress them even though you can still
submit these things online to
open uh what is like the um
these open journals that is you can you
can it's like a pre-print service where
you can
upload things online so they can't
suppress your ideas
before they're published like you get
your ideas published on
uh on one of these open source areas
before they get accepted
um and it's i just really i really
wish both brett and his brother would
sort of go that route
and actual actually write up the paper
whether or not you're going to submit it
to a journal
but just have something that we can look
at where i can actually assess what's
being talked about here because
it's just it's just a big black box and
maybe they're
geniuses who are gonna just turn the
paradigm of evolution or
or maybe not like i just have nothing to
go off of so i guess we'll see
it definitely feels like a fan of bread
dude this isn't like there's not a con
i'm not like
kind of butt heads with him i'm just i
want to see more because he's
he's a smart guy he's the kind of person
that i could see maybe coming up with
some brilliant idea
uh i just as a biologist myself i
i just want to know more i'm super
interested in what he what he's
proposing
it definitely feels to me like him and
eric have had
such burnt finger syndrome
from the traditional avenues of academia
that um it kind of doesn't surprise me i
didn't know that about their
aversion to publishing in traditional
journals and putting together the papers
in the normal way but it totally doesn't
surprise me given what i know about
their
background yeah i mean it's not even
that they won't publish in journals like
i'm fine if they just
publish it on a blog or something you
know to just write the paper
so i can see where it is and we can
assess it on its on its own merits
right if you if you are listening my
friend there is a lot of people out here
that want to know what's going on the
next thing
next thing that i was really interested
in we will loop back to this kind of
uh recent narrative restricting what
people can and can't talk about within
your field
but what area do you disagree with
colleagues that you think are mostly
rationable
rational and reasonable in your uh
evolutionary biology field on what is it
that you guys
don't agree on is there anything kind of
juicy that's not the obvious stuff
yeah well it depends how what you mean
by obvious i guess like there's
obvious things that yeah that's that's
sort of the obvious
area that people outside realize is that
you know um
sex differences is of course sort of
like this whole controversial thing both
outside and within
uh but there's also i mean i'm i studied
collective behavior animal personality
social behavior in
uh you social insects and also in
spiders
and when you start getting into the
social evolution literature
you kind of start butting heads uh with
these two factions that
uh a lot of times when you go to
your undergrad and in some cases grad
school
you learn about these two different
modes of of evolution for social
behavior there's sort of this
um individual selectionist model that's
basically founded on on kin selection
which is
this notion that you might behave uh you
know altruistic
or seemingly altruistic towards
individuals because you share like a
higher proportion of your genes with
them and so it's actually not
you know you're not doing anything
actually to benefit them but
you're benefiting yourself or these
copies of your genes sort of
indirectly by helping other individuals
this is kind of like a
an altruistic uh trait that can evolve
um and sort of explains uh why we're
actually nice to other individuals when
you might
predict that we'd just be selfish all
the time
uh there's also other models within that
like reciprocal altruism like i'll
scratch your back you scratch mine
things like that
then there's a whole other kind of way
of thinking that's
a lot of times used as sort of like this
whipping boy in classes
it's sort of this notion of group
selection that like groups themselves
can evolve traits at the group level
that benefit the individuals within it
uh so it's not just
driven by individual selection at sort
of like this this lower rate but you can
actually have
selection between entire groups of
individuals that is going to select for
sort of like a collective type of
behavior that's way more controversial
there's there tends to be this so the
history of it
kind of is the reason why it's so
controversial is because some of the
early days when they discussed these
ideas this guy named wynn edwards he
sort of had this idea of
uh of group selection as you'd have
maybe individuals sacrificing their body
for the good of the group for the good
of the species
uh and it turns out this is sort of like
a
just a cartoon version of of group
selection like you're never going to get
sort of like this sacrificial uh
trait that can evolve in a population
because any individual that has
this trait for you know committing
suicide for the group
if it's beneficial well they die and
they take that gene with them they're
out of the gene pool so it's not going
to spread through the gene pool
but there's sort of this more i guess
nuanced version
of group selection that sort of looks at
selection at multiple levels
they call it multi-level selection i
think it's much less controversial
at least it makes more theoretic sense
even though there's still a lot of
people who will
just think people are crazy within the
field and there's heated debates between
multi-level selection and the kin
selectionists
uh people you know walking out of
conference talks because they're
you know having this certain opinion and
you know getting papers you know
rejected and things like that it's super
brutal and you would never guess that i
love the idea of this
stuff academic debate is just like you
know there's i've heard stories people
at conference and they're just like at
the urinal next to each other and they
see the other person who's
a group selectionist and they're just
you know they can't even they can't even
like pee next to them
and it's so it's it's the ultimate like
pettiness i think
and i think a lot of it too is people
are talking past each other in these
uh you know they're just volleying these
these five thousand word papers back to
each other in reviews
where i think you know something just
like this like a podcast like i just
want to get two of these sites
i could get them on joe rogan or
something and just just let them hash it
out where they can just talk because
i think they both make really good
points and i can't really put myself in
any one camp
so but that's a might be a controversy
people aren't really aware of
yeah on the outside did you look at how
collective intelligence works for
insects stuff like ants in a
a big colony and and stuff like that
because that's always been something
that's fascinated me
yeah not intelligence per se i i looked
at really their
their collective behavior um and how we
can predict
the behavior of the of the entire group
based on knowing the behavior of uh in
spiders knowing the behavior of sort of
the the composition of every individual
so
and then when i study this in wasps i
would look at how
we can predict the the uh behavior of
the entire colony and it's also future
survival and fitness
based on just knowing the personality
traits of the queen
uh in the beginning of the season before
you know any
colony even exists where it's just a
solitary foundress wasp queens have
personalities
oh yeah almost everything has
personalities in in nature
so okay what are the different
personalities that a
a wasp queen can have
so there's there's so many different
axes of behavior the main ones people
test
are things like aggressiveness and uh
boldness um there's
sort of these uh tests of how how
well they're startled by like novel
objects uh
there's like gregariousness um
all of these words all these words sound
like exactly what wasps do
but i'm not a massive fan of wasps and
this is you can also
you can also look at like their foraging
behavior exploration
uh sort of how well they learn
nest construction things like this those
are kind of some of them might not be
seen as like traditionally personality
traits but a personality really is just
any consistent behavior that exists
uh that an individual has that's
consistent throughout its life or more
specifically like
consistent individual differences in
behavior that exist in a population
uh so certain individuals behave one way
in this one context and
they behave a similar way in multiple
contexts it's really just sort of like a
um the common sense i guess idea of what
personality is you know if you're
an aggressive person you're going to be
aggressive in
you know from when you're young to when
you're old and probably across different
contexts so it's just sort of a
scientific version of what we sort of
normally think about when we talk about
personalities
and just as you know no two individuals
have the same personality
uh what my research did was sort of
apply that same principle but to entire
groups and looking at the emergent
behavior
of an entire colony and how does this
one colony differ in its behavior
from other colonies and how are they you
know dividing labor up among individuals
how do they respond to
you know being attacked or something or
being disturbed basically any sort of
context that would be relevant for
their survival of a group what do you
work
been focused on for the last few years i
know that you've uh
taken a little bit of a left turn with
regards to your career recently so what
have you been focused on yeah
um while i was in academia or not in
academia
my last few years so after it hasn't
been so much
academic research in sort of the
you know the the type i would be doing
if i'm in a lab or something like that
since i don't have
the same funding i do now that i'm not
in academia so it's it's more sort of a
literature-based
uh approach to doing research i've been
very interested in sex differences in
humans and also
animals generally how
sex differences arise a lot of more
behavioral psychology i'm sort of trying
to get into that literature and also the
human personality literature because
human personality is actually tested
quite differently than
animal personality is done there's
different traits that are looked at i
mean there's some overlap but
basically you can't ask an animal to
fill out a survey and so you can't
get at some of the nuances that you can
get into people but then at the same
time like animals aren't going to try to
deceive you the way a human might try to
do or try to make themselves appear
better on paper so there's
there's benefits and disadvantages to
to each and i think it's be really
interesting to see if
how many bridges can be drawn between
sort of the human personality literature
animal personality literature and also
going into like some of jonathan heights
research with the moral foundations and
stuff and
how do those relate to human personality
differences too and can we
look at how these map onto political
parties
and individual types of behavior can we
find
you know keystone individuals which are
just sort of individuals that
have a disproportionate influence on the
behavior of groups and any other
individual
which could be important for things like
writing or you know all kinds of
interesting questions so i've just been
kind of exploring all kinds of stuff
which has been super nice because
back when i was in academia i was
studying ants and spiders and wasps a
lot and so everything i'm reading is
just like
ants spiders and wasps but now i've just
sort of just
blown it open like i can research
anything i want to now and it's
it's been really refreshing actually as
much as i love ant spiders and wasps
uh it would be i'd probably have to
switch systems at some point just to
remain
sane because man you can only read so
many of those
there's an upper bound on how much you
can research insects man like
being in the trenches talking about
gender and sex differences for the last
few years must have been
he must have been like the vanguard and
the lord of the rings two towers
battle yeah i mean it's
i never expected that that's kind of
where i'd end up
you know staking my ground uh in the
culture war i guess but
i think yeah i didn't i didn't choose it
really it's just
i've always been sort of somebody who
tries to like debunk things i used to
have a blog back in the day where i
would just debunk
weird pseudoscience like sort of ancient
chinese medicine or something you know
just things like that so i was always
very sort of combative
uh in that sense of trying to like
debunk pseudoscience
and i guess i just had just
in my opinion i saw what i would appear
to be pseudoscience coming
from inside the academy rather than from
the outside
uh so yeah there's a lot more there's a
lot more consequences when you decide to
speak up
from within the institution against
other people that are in the institution
rather than speaking out against
ancient chinese medicine or against
creation science where they don't really
have a foothold
in academia in the first place so yeah
it's been an interesting
couple years for sure are you surprised
that the argument about
the gender and sex differences and how
we define that is still going i mean
jordan peterson has been in and out of
rehab
in the time that this debate's been
going
how is this how is it still going is
there still more
for us to discuss
i mean i don't think there's a lot to
discuss really i mean it
it seems pretty cut and dry that we can
just
distinguish between what biological sex
is
and what gender identity is and know
that these things are completely
different things
and just move on from there like this
shouldn't be a difficult
division to be making yet somehow this
is just you know we're getting
things sometimes in the new york times
or even in nature
magazine the most prestigious journal in
the world that's making claims that
you know sex is a spectrum or that uh
you can't determine
individual sex based on anatomy or
genetics like that's a claim that
they've made in nature magazine before
in an editorial
that they did and this is the most
extreme claims i can imagine coming out
of a biologist's mouth
uh so yeah it's it's truly bizarre
what is what occupies what's the
definition
that you use of gender and of sex
so for for sex so there's sort of like
two
levels to look at it and this is where a
lot of confusion sort of arises
is that there's sex as sort of a concept
if we're talking about you know males
and females
and when you're looking at a population
of organisms if you're asking like does
this population
is it does it sexually reproduce okay if
the answer is yes then you say like what
kind of system does it have are they
isogamic which means do they have uh
individuals
that aren't really males or females but
they might have two different mating
types
um where they have the same size gamete
basically which is
you know when when there's males or
females it's sperm or ova
but some species don't have these two
dichotomous things they're just
sort of the similar size of gametes
that'll come together and create
offspring
what's an example of that what's an
example of that animal what animals
would fall into that category
uh there's like mainly there's a lot of
plants that have that like some fungus
um you know i don't know there's some
sea organisms that have sort of this
type of
yeah i'm sure there's many i'm missing i
i don't focus too much on the
isogamic species because they're not
that particularly interesting to me but
when you get to the the existence of a
male and female and what those are as
sort of a concept
uh when you're looking at a population
is the the individuals that are creating
uh the small gametes whatever it is you
know sperm if you're
a tree it's you know you're making
pollen or something uh those are
considered the males and the females are
the ones that are producing the large
gametes that are basically stationary
but then there gets
to the point where uh when you want to
actually assign or
record the sex of individual organisms
that we come up with this
you know up against something where it
says like well you know males before
they reach puberty they are not actually
creating
sperm they don't produce any so are they
sexless because they don't produce
small gametes and so when you're
actually sexing individual bodies
you sort of look at what their uh
primary sex organs you know their gonads
what are they what's the developmental
trajectory that they've taken is it
have they developed to uh organized
around producing
sperm or organized around producing ova
you know are these basically are they
are they testes uh or is it ovarian
tissue
is what kind of ad base comes down to
um but you get a lot of people that that
try to use things like secondary sex
characteristics like the characteristics
that we
we get after puberty so like you know
females who get breasts in their
their body fats distributed differently
over their body males sort of gets
more upper body strength and our jaws
become more chiseled all that type of
stuff
they conflate that with biological sex
so they're they're sort of looking at
the appearance of
of bodies and how a body looks generally
and they're saying that because that's
sort of
on a spectrum and you can have you know
masculine looking
females and feminine looking males
that's sort of
how they're trying to quantify sex even
though that's that's not what sex is
at all um and then you asked about
gender
i don't really have a definition of
gender there's there's like five
out there and i just i find it almost
it really depends on what they mean when
they say it so whenever someone asks me
about gender i always say like well
what definition do you have like i'm a
biologist so
i'm when i talk about males and females
i know exactly what we're talking about
in that context because it's a very it's
a scientific definition it's very
precise
uh but there are some people that have
definitions of gender that
um you know you have like the radical
feminist definition which is sort of the
societal roles and expectations that are
placed on individuals based on their
perceived sex
so we might associate women with being
more submissive or
more caring for offering that type of
thing it means more aggressive and
dominant and that type of stuff
there's the idea of like gender identity
and it's sort of like it's internal
feeling of
of masculinity or femininity you know
however those are defined
it's usually sort of reduced to sort of
gendered sex
stereotypes um and then there's
yeah there's sort of psychological
definitions there's more activist
oriented definitions
there's like the tumblr definition where
it's just like everyone's got this
gender identity and here's a list of
a hundred of them and you can just you
know pick one off of it you're
you know a neutron or whatever you know
bi-gender
pan-gender gender fluid like there's all
those two
which is just sort of like the the
pokemon approach to gender is i usually
like kind of describe it there's just a
huge list
so yeah i don't know what gender is if
someone gives me a definition i can just
at least know we're talking about and
see if they're
differentiating it from biological sex
that's kind of what i care about like
people can talk about gender as much as
they want to as long as they don't tread
on
sort of the scientific definition of
biological sex and try to blur that
boundary in some sort of way
so gender is more the expression
of the particular sexual characteristics
that
or or not or the counter to the
particular sexual
characteristics that an individual has
yeah i think that's mostly the most
common
sort of way people think about it i
suppose um there's a political divide
too like
conservatives will basically don't
distinguish between sex and gender
uh also like radical feminists too so
they their definition of
you know what a man and a woman is is
just like an adult human male or female
so they don't really add that social
component sometimes they do sometimes
they don't
it just depends what's intersex that's a
is that another sex
so it's it's not another sex it's just
sort of
defined as either being sexually
ambiguous or there being sort of a
mismatch between
uh your internal sex organs
and external appearance so you can have
certain individuals say that have
uh like complete androgen and
sensitivity syndrome
where their their cells don't respond to
testosterone at all like
they don't they don't receive signals to
develop uh
based on the presence of testosterone um
and also when in utero too so they they
might be born and look 100
female and then they grow up too and
they still
they look 100 female they might be on
average a little bit taller
but you know when puberty comes around
they they don't
uh they don't start menstruating and
then they usually go to the doctor like
why
why aren't i menstruating and it turns
out they have internal
testes and they just their body hasn't
doesn't respond to the testosterone that
they're making so they just never
develop
to look like a male even though you know
inside they're they're biologically male
in a in a very
real sense um but it's not a third sex
because if you look at the definition of
sex it's it's basically the organization
around
uh producing sperm or producing ova
since there's not a third intermediate
gamete between
sperm or ova there's not really a third
sex like there's there's variations of
body types
but there aren't you know there isn't
like a third gamete that
is is out there to be a third sex even
like a hermaphrodite uh even like a
simultaneous hermaphrodite if you have
an individual that can produce birth
both sperm or ova which hasn't really
been shown in humans
that would be an example of someone
being sort of both male and female
there wouldn't be like a new still not a
third thing yeah
yeah they're not like i tend to use like
colors you can have like
uh if you have like red golf balls and
green golf balls
you know and you have a another golf
ball that's like half of it is red and
half of it is green
like well like red green isn't its own
unique color it's just like a
combination of red
and green you know it's it's you can you
can mix them
but that's not what like a hermaphrodite
is they're like both at the same time
so yeah there's there's some nuances
there uh
but a lot of the some people on both
sides do they just sort of
throw the nuance out the window and they
don't want to sort of get in the details
of what they're actually talking about
yeah what do people mean when they say
that gender is a social construct
then yeah so when they say that
if they say gender is a social contract
it's usually that their radical feminist
view that
sort of there will be these societal
expectations
and norms that we build up socially
uh that we come to expect of people that
look male or female
so you know like for example if you're
if you're like an effeminate male
growing up
they probably get really uh bullied by
their friends
to some degree or other maybe not their
close friends but you might get bullied
for being like a [ __ ] or something like
that or if you're
a super tomboy you know you might get
bullied because you know you're not
particularly feminine
and so that that's sort of the the
social aspect
of making individuals trying to conform
to these stereotypes of masculinity or
femininity
and so in a way gender is constructed
kind of that way by society that's
sort of having people try to conform to
these these
these these norms of masculinity and
femininity
uh there's also a biological component
where you know males are on average more
likely to behave in a certain way that
conforms to masculinity or femininity
but
uh the social construct is sort of like
the the other societal roles that we
ascribe to these
uh to these different sexes um is this
the social component that we sort of
put into our culture i guess might be
the best way to describe it
and there's there's certain renditions
of that that i think are interesting
that
that can need to be talked about um
but then you get some people who are
saying sex and gender are all social
constructs and they sort of mean
what they mean by that is they don't
actually exist there's no such thing as
sex differences at all
because there's overlap between males
and females you can't say that they
actually differ
and you know that's they're all involved
in just trying to blur
boundaries between anything so we can't
make any statements about
you know average group differences and
things like that so there's there's more
nuanced and more
messy ways to approach uh these
questions
it feels like they're all messy ways it
feels like every single one of them is
a messy way yeah i think the main
difference is some
people are being maybe intentionally uh
trying to obfuscate things and
not offer clarity they're only trying to
blur
things and then people like like me and
and
others are are trying to just you know
saying like yeah there's a lot of
complexity sometimes boundaries are a
little blurry but that doesn't mean we
can't make
sort of general true statements about
average differences
uh between groups uh according to some
sort of
uh you know their sex or whatever it
might be
how much of this is a semantic game do
you think
oh it's almost entirely a semantic game
like when i
if i'm talking to people who are or
activists they'll they'll use
the words that are you know those say
gender or something like i'll make a
statement like
biological sex isn't a spectrum and then
they'll they'll counter with
you know like no gender is a spectrum
well i didn't say gender i said
biological sex and a lot of times the
rebuttals to my articles will be
you know all my articles are all about
biological sex and they'll
they'll sort of refer to biological sex
then they'll have a sentence where they
sort of pivot to gender identity and
then the rest of the article will be
about gender identity and
they'll just do their whole gender thing
after that and it's like that's not
responding
to anything i'm saying uh and that's
just
yeah there's they'll use gender in a
context or sex in a context depending on
like
what is the kind of the most expedient
way to to like win an argument to some
degree it seems
um maybe i'm being a little a little
harsh on them but this is what it seems
like
at least from my perspective yeah it it
reminds me a little bit i was talking to
douglas murray earlier this year
and he brought up black lives matter and
the fact that you have semantic overload
within that terminology
and even this year you saw
certain people when referring to the
group
calling it blm and then so that you
could kind of semantically distance
yourself
from the term black lives matter and
it seems a little bit like there's a
common thread perhaps
between that and what's going on here
yeah i mean one one good example
is whenever i talk about intersex
individuals if people ask what that is
some people will say you know like a
developmental error or something has
taken place
or uh there'll be some other word that's
just like you know
there's a it's a it's a condition
or something like that which i think you
need to use some word because it's not
like
the norm of sexual development and then
so if you were to say that like a
developmental error has taken place
they'll then switch it around and say
like oh are you calling me an error
like i'm an error like they'll take that
word and they'll describe it to like
them as a person
and you know it's just no one's calling
like
you as a person an error like they're
just saying that
at some point of development you know if
someone if someone developed and they
were
born with you know with only one arm
like you can
say that there's an error in development
has taken place that led to
a limb missing you're not calling them
an error you know they're still a
100 human uh but this is like the
semantic game where they're always
trying to
kind of bait you into saying something
that they can then construe as you being
a terrible person or something and to to
then
go on and make you you know try to smear
your reputation or something
yeah and i suppose that gender dysphoria
uh
in its most extreme uh
manifestations could be described as an
error and
quite rightly so like the people who are
living within that particular body
feel like that body isn't for them if
that's not
a glossary definition of what an error
is
then i'm not sure but as you get further
and further down the boundary obviously
you have no way to know
my level of gender dysphoria is a 10
yours is only at the five yours is only
at a two years at a minus two you feel
perfectly happy being in a man's body or
a woman's body um
i suppose that again that degree of the
degrees of freedom for interpretation
just further muddy the water
yeah it becomes an error when you move
beyond
just saying that like i sort of feel
like i've been born of the wrong body to
people saying that like that's literally
the case like i've
i was assigned the wrong sex at birth
and you know that's that's just what it
is i'm actually this other sex
it's like that's just not literally true
and i just think we have a
responsibility to be
precise about what is actually true in
these situations because if you're
if you're just going to bend over
backwards and let them you know redefine
their own bodies you know like alchemy
or something then just based on what
they feel
then you just there's just nothing they
can't just
believe and have be true i mean we need
to have some sort of grounding principle
uh that tethers us to reality to some
degree
uh so yeah that's kind of what i'm
concerned about you know if
if we can reject something as is as
clear-cut
in most cases as biological sexes
if that can be just dismissed
you know in mass by a whole bunch of
people
there's just nothing else like what
other things are we gonna start
just saying aren't real like age like
what i mean you already get people
saying some of that stuff too and it's
you know i see it as just a hill
that i'm willing to die on because
there's
it's just there's no there's no stopping
if we get past this point like this is
one of the
most obvious truths i think that we can
i can only state as a biologist
so uh i'll just keep saying it i suppose
it's not working out okay for me it's
that classic uh ben shapiro video right
why aren't you 60
why aren't you 60 basically i think that
yeah i mean
i don't know man like what has happened
over the last 15 years to cause this to
rise to prominence
because i went to school 15 years ago
and this wasn't i
i wasn't hearing this sort of rhetoric
pushed at all
yeah i mean it's good to go to people
like
you know helen pluck rose and james
lindsay who can trace sort of like the
ideological
underpinnings of the the movement and
the ideologies
it comes down to at least for you know
the whole
sex denialism stuff that's just uh
the humanities and and specifically
queer theory that's just basically
involved in trying to
destroy any sort of binary and make
everything as blurry as possible
and then problematize things where if
you disagree you're a horrible person
it's that that sort of post-modern way
of looking at things where it's all
about discourses and power dynamics and
uh it was present you know it wasn't
like it didn't exist back
you know when i was in undergrad it was
it was just just kind of starting there
and i went to undergrad when i was
you know 2008 to 2012 i think
and it was there but it wasn't it wasn't
like a dominant view at the time
i there were some activists that would
talk about that and i would just be like
okay that sounds crazy
and i just never thought about it again
because i didn't have to
and then you know of course when i then
went to you know i graduated then i went
to grad school and
got my doctorate then at the time i was
started looking for jobs now it's
that's the dominant view and there are
so many people in
just my field right now other biologists
who are making these same claims it's
just like it's superseding
the science in many ways and uh i know a
lot of the people that i've even
co-authored papers with they think i'm
just like this horrible
horrible person now just for writing
some essays in colette
it's just amazing did you say that um
someone or a number of people had
reached out to you basically forewarning
you that they were going to have to do a
public announcement about the fact that
they are not associated with you they do
not
believe what you believe and they have
to kind of do it behind the scenes to
you just so that in front of the scenes
they can
make this show of force i mean it was it
was someone who'd co-authored papers
with me and
you know i'm always fine with people who
want to disagree with me even publicly
like i don't if they're
i don't like take offense to that it
doesn't make doesn't
make me feel like i'm being attacked
because i
i just think ideas need to be attacked
as long as it's not saying bad things
about me directly
uh i'm fine with it and this was a this
was a close friend and
uh he just said yeah i'm gonna i need to
write something because
and the scariest part is that you know i
think he actually disagreed with me
which is fine
but it wasn't just the fact that he
disagreed with me people saw like his
colleagues saw that we had been
you know we were friends before we had
co-authored papers
he saw my name on a paper next to his
and it was this mutual policing like
they went to him and they're they're
making him sort of justify
him ever associating with me and he was
worried that just because of
sort of the the fire that's going on and
you know
with me and the controversy that that
sort of sprung up that there was going
to be splash damage on his career
and that he needed to distance himself
from me
uh and so i think there's just such an
exemplary of the
the mutual policing going on that he
felt that he had this pressure
to condemn my views that before he was
just silent on the issue he didn't he
didn't even care
uh but it was yeah it was the social
coercion of his colleagues where he felt
he needed to
you know do a public denunciation
which that's the scariest part because
that's it's so true
at least in my experience that is the
the cultural aspect of academia and the
the way that you know you need to be
you need to have allies to do good
science especially in my field of
evolution and ecology you need
collaborators you need to have people
going on grants with you
and they can essentially make your
career impossible to move forward
just by not wanting to to speak with you
not wanting to associate with you and
that's
sort of what he's not coming his way if
he didn't make a public
you know denunciation so that's that's
the scariest part
what do you wish people were spending
their time talking about or thinking
about
rather than debating gender because
there's this famous douglas murray line
where he says
when the barbarians are at the gate
we'll be debating about what gender they
are whilst we all get kalashnikov in the
head
and i've been reading a lot of
existential risk recently
i'm absolutely terrified about the
advent of misaligned artificial general
intelligence and
nanotechnology turning us all into grey
goo or
bio weapons or engineered pandemics or
natural pandemics
like if 20 if there was ever going to be
a year
that should have realigned our values
was 2020 not the one
and that why hasn't it brought us yes
why hasn't it brought our values back in
line
yeah i think the things we need to talk
about it's not necessarily things we're
not talking about i just think we're
talking about things
in the complete opposite way we should
be talking about them like i think it's
important to talk about things like
like racism in society it's important to
talk about whether or not there are
environmental components to behavioral
differences between
sexes or or whatever species you're
talking about like
it but we just need to have a more sober
conversation where we don't
leave some explanations they're just off
the table before the conversation even
begins um you can't talk about
uh like things like any any sort of
cultural inertia that any sort
of population might have uh
regardless of where it's coming from in
the world like we can't talk about
any of those sort of factors like any
cultural factors whatsoever that could
be predictive of of a differential group
outcomes like that's just off the table
you can't talk about those
at all uh you know if you're looking at
police violence or whatever
like if there were papers that were
published
in prestigious journals like pnas that
you know looked at
uh police shootings and didn't find any
correlation between this you know
i think it was actual uh people who were
like armed who were shot by police they
didn't find like a racial component to
that
and heather mcdonald who comments a lot
about
race issues she had some articles in the
wall street journal about this
highlighting this research and it was
one of the biggest data sets
in the wake of you know george floyd
the authors of that paper nothing wrong
with the paper
they just said that they wanted to
retract it because they were
getting hammered by people saying that
this research is
racist and you know but again the data
there was there was nothing wrong you
usually only retract papers
if there's a flaw if the
interpretation's off
and usually it's just not even a
retraction unless it was like data
fabrication was found
if it's if it's just a bad
interpretation you can you can amend
them you can say like oh we need to
issue a you know an addendum onto this
thing but no they just
fully retracted it uh that's called
pulling that's called pulling the
ejector seat
oh yeah they just they just memory hold
this paper like it doesn't even exist
anymore
you can't cite it now if you try to cite
it you're going to be like oh you're a
crackpot citing
this paper that's been you know this
it's been uh
retracted and it's like well no there's
nothing wrong with the data and heather
mcdonnell even said like you know
they've retracted it because
i accurately portrayed their research in
the wall street journal and that's
basically what happens
so we're going to get this situation now
where the only research people are
willing to publish
is that this aligns with any a certain
political narrative and it's just
you can't you can't trust the experts
anymore it's just it's horrible
the environment is so salted and
scorched earth that
there's just it's not a friendly
environment to actually
go into and try to ask a question and be
okay with any outcome even if it's
sort of doesn't align with what we'd
like to be true
is this still on an upward trajectory in
academia
because it keeps on seeming to me as
someone who consumes a lot of content
and has been a fly on the wall watching
this for the last few years
first off it was the sort of thing that
was students on campus well you don't
really have to worry because they're
just students on campus and when they
grow up they'll hit the real world and
the real world will sort them out
and then it started to sort of move into
policy of private companies
and you saw netflix and other companies
have some kind of like weird policies
about eye contact and
and then it starts to move into press
and you see some increasingly
bizarre headlines that for if you were
to give to your mum or dad
kind of salt of the earth people
probably wouldn't make a massive amount
of
sense and now we're seeing politicians
and we're seeing
public policy like is it
still a growing concern because to me
like
it's still not something i've ever
encountered irl
personally and up until that point it's
almost a little bit like
people laughing in in a different
in a different world uh but
i'm sure that it's going to come and
arrive at our door this
denial of facts no matter what your
particular beliefs are around the topics
that we've gone through today
there is a lot of fact denial both sides
can't be right
so there is fact denial going on like
yeah what's going on yeah
well it definitely arrived at my door
which was shocking to me because the
reason i decided to
i wanted to be an academic you know 12
years ago when i decided to
major in a as a biologist
um was because i wanted to work you know
at the frontier of
uh biological research and i thought
what better environment to
what could be more intellectually
stimulating than talking about
certain issues and being only driven by
facts
uh with a bunch of other experts in the
field and things like that and that just
turned out
not to be the case you know i i had said
that same
mantra that you you referred to is um
sort of you know when you get into the
real world
you know you're not going to have these
like i used to say something like you
know the real world doesn't have
trigger warnings and it turns out it
does now
there are they've
they've modified their environment
to accommodate them like you know the
same way that humans have sort of
you know we we need shelter and so we've
now reached a position where we've
we've created houses so now we don't
have to brave the elements they've sort
of just created
the same equivalent they've just made
safe spaces in places where we said that
they
they didn't exist um and
it's definitely getting way worse like
it's
yeah we're nowhere near the peak of this
i don't think
because it's just exploded and over the
last six months like it's
just gotten everywhere i mean we see the
diversity equity and inclusion
statements that are taking over
all the i can't it's hard to apply to
university now where i don't have to
fill out this
diversity equity and inclusion statement
which is basically a
political litmus test that i pledge
allegiance to this sort of way of
thinking about racial issues
uh that i just really don't agree with
um it's not because i'm like a bigot or
anything it's just i
i think of more liberal approaches is
more warranted and some of the words are
used in ways that
you know the non-standard definitions
and
yeah it's it's creating this feedback
loop
loop in academia too where you get you
know you have a bunch of people on
hiring committees who have these
ideologies and they'll only hire others
people that have these ideologies and
social media makes it so you can find
out someone's political beliefs and
might not think these are influencing
your hiring decision but they almost
certainly are like what's the chances
that someone has a
public facebook and they have a maga hat
on or something they could be the best
you know a microbiologist in the world
they're not going to get hired by
berkeley like they're just not going to
get a job there
period especially if they don't fill out
the uh diversity statement the way that
they want it to be done
berkeley has a rubric of how exactly to
respond to these and what types of
answers are wrong so they're like
they're leading you to tell you like
here's what you need to say like
say the words say them and it's it's
just
it's a nightmare and it's just going to
get worse once once you get
this feedback loop where you get more
and more skewed towards one political
orientation that's just
it's just gonna go to fixation it's
gonna be 100 and then
where do you go from there like how do
you how do you reverse it
if everyone shares the same blind spot
there's no one there to point it out to
him anymore so
it's like some sort of brutal malthusian
trap
oh yeah um do you think post-modernism
is slowing human progress
oh yeah it just has to because it's just
not tethered to
reality i mean there might be like sort
of a nugget of truth that
is at the center of their concerns but
when you go about to try to actually
try to base a policy or some action uh
and your basis is post-modernism that's
just
assumes that power's the thing that
permeates everything
and that truth is created
through narratives and there's not like
an objective reality or at least we
can't come to objective
knowledge about that reality
there's just nothing you can't you can't
go anywhere there's no traction to go
direction
are the effects sufficiently widespread
now that they're actually making a
genuine impact on our
ability to move forward as a
civilization as well
oh i think so i mean just on almost
every issue that we care most about
the the main uh
i guess the ideology du jour is is
rooted in in post-modernism like almost
entirely
you look at just sort of the critical
race theory approach to
how they want to solve racism and it's
just measured by let's look at
outcomes let's look at any disparity of
outcomes and that's just going to be
if there are these disparities that is
the definition of
institutional structural racism and end
of story and we need to
fix the outcomes rather than try to
solve something at the
beginning of the pipeline because
they've convinced themselves it's not a
pipeline issue it's just sort of a
systemic issue uh and that
you know the only way we can do it to
fix things is by you know just
having certain some sort of racial
quotas is what it usually boils down to
in the end
are there any areas that are still
holding fast
is there any area of academia or
research which is yet to be
slowed by this
yeah some of the more i mean i guess
stereotypically hard sciences
like particle physics and
you know i'm certain i'm sure that like
a lot of engineers
i mean i've seen post-modern papers that
are
about sort of uh trying to deconstruct
like engineering and and
physics and cosmology and stuff i i
don't think they have any influence
whatsoever right now but they're
they're definitely trying to get a
foothold and somehow
they've managed to get some of these
insane papers published in these
in decent journals just because no one
wants to reject the paper because
they'll be
you know almost certainly accused of
some some range of bigotry
uh by if they were to reject it
so yeah it's it's con it's it's sort of
has a wedge everywhere but some place is
going to be a lot harder to
to drive it through because at some
point
with engineering you're the bridge needs
to stand you know like
there needs the fields where there's
going to be a real world
like bridge collapsing somewhere
something that's just like
that obviously is not a stable bridge
something that like
reality will just break down everything
and make it really apparent that
this is incorrect those are going to be
hard if not impossible to really
completely take over
um i may not maybe i say that now but
who knows
it seems like you you keep on using the
word hard science and that's kind of the
one that appears to be
the last stand at the moment for
rationality
has the last five to ten years
been a stress test for all academic
disciplines
in that way yeah some more than others
for sure
um the stress it's harder for some to
survive the stress test because
some of the ideas that they're dealing
with if if they're actually
if they're wrong about something like in
my field ecology for instance
we're dealing with super complex
variables we're looking at the way
populations are interacting with your
environment and the environments change
and the
populations are changing genetically
over time and complex behaviors
you can make some broad you know
measurements about how these
how how things are happening between
groups or something but
it's not a very precise science it's it
requires
long-term studies to get like anything
that's
is going to be super robust and so if
you're wrong about something
in ecology or in psychology or some of
these other sciences that are just so
complex to
to measure you don't get that moment of
watching a bridge collapse
you know that you would get as an
engineer who
the rocket doesn't explode the rocket
doesn't explode like
an exploding rocket and a collapsing
bridge those are just immediate ways to
know like
we really messed up here but some other
fields you're not gonna know you've
messed up
until you know a while or never
depending on how you get
you know if you have certain narratives
that are getting published more and
you're not accepting
other things to get published that could
potentially debunk these things
there might be you know there's these
cryptic you know
crumbling bridges that are in there
waiting to be discovered but they just
might not be discovered
uh and so yeah so that's that's the
that's the stress test is like
is the do you have a an objective test
of failure
uh that's gonna be so readily apparent
to everybody
um and a lot of fields just don't have
that uh
it's much more nuanced and requires
a lot more rigor i guess as well in
fields that are based on interpretation
when you think about what a lot of
literature is what a lot of philosophy
is
it's abstract thought it's thinking
about thinking it's interpreting
it interpreting uh past
passages and ideas and by its very
nature that level of abstraction
uh adds slippage into the system where
people can
slide nefarious
ideas yeah i mean any of those fields
yeah where they're just thinking about
thinking
i mean once you once you go down a
pathway like there's no corrective
mechanism to get back on the trail
you're just going to be walking out in
the woods
forever and ever so
yeah you you need to have some tether to
reality like there needs to be some sort
of external check
you need to have some uh what is it the
uh
theory of knowledge where it's it's uh
it's it's based on feedback from
nature basically you have to have some
way of being falsified some way of
some outcome where you could say oh yeah
we're clearly wrong on that because
we didn't expect that outcome or we
predicted this outcome and that's not
what we got
um yeah you need to be some way to test
alternative hypotheses and you just
don't get that in some fields of
philosophy especially those that are
based on you know the
the post-modern thing where you're just
narratives
is like the foundation of it all as an
evolutionary biologist do you find it
hilarious or interesting that this
to me seems like a massive status game
that everybody is just status signaling
left right and center
state is signaling that they're not
state to signaling tearing down other
people who
are that that must be fascinating to you
it really is yeah i mean there was a
paper i might
i might butcher the interpretation of it
but it was like it was an evolutionary
psychology paper that was
talking about how it was like an
evolutionary psychological explanation
for the reason why certain ideas are
being suppressed like it just
it fitted the entire like suppression of
ideas within a framework
of evolutionary psychology and how it's
just sort of like these tribal
uh mentalities that are going going at
one another
um and just you know basically predicted
like this is what we would expect if
evolutionary psychology was true we'd
have these certain groups that are
trying to suppress these ideas and
signal in these certain ways
uh you get to the smallest little things
too
like you know pronoun usage or something
just in your bio or in your signature of
your
email and these are like you know you
don't need to be aware
of what those are doing like at a
ultimate level
uh for it to be actually influenced by
some evolutionary force so like people
who have the parents
they might tell themselves that these i
have these pronouns just because it's a
nice thing it's
creating an inclusive environment or
something like that for certain
minorities or something
but what these turn into and what the
real function i think of these things
are is
is what turns into a um sort of like
this in group signaling where you see
other people sort of like someone who
wears a cross or something on there
on their on their shirt like you you can
identify these individuals who share
a wide range of your beliefs and you
know they're in the in group
but then once this becomes more
expansive and more and more people are
using this
and almost every email i get from a
university professor has them in their
bios and
on their twitter profile it's less of
like identifying the in
group with given that everyone now knows
that
pronouns and bios and email signatures
is a thing
it says more now when you don't have it
in your bio so it becomes more of like a
way to identify like this out group and
there's just so so many evolutionary
dynamics that are going on here with
forming tribal identities and how easy
it is to form these identities
and how you know if these identities are
ever challenged how how easy they're
just
defended super hard like if they're
challenged to any degree so
you have this imbalance of of how easy
it is to form identities and then how
how much people double down on those
easily formed identities when they're
challenged
and it just breeds this tribalism that
you were getting
in almost every area of of political
discourse nowadays
have you read scott alexander's blog
post i can tolerate anything except the
out group
i don't think i've heard that i've read
some of his stuff i really need to go
and do like a deep dive on his because
every time i've read his
stuff they're just incredibly thoughtful
he's phenomenal man so
i implore everyone that's listening to
go and check that out i'll send it to
you once we're done man it's
it's yeah awesome and it
just identifies how much fear
everybody has around not being part of
that in group
and it's so unbelievably compelling and
upon
deep diving down the evolutionary
psychology
red pill rabbit hole earlier this year
it's shown me
just how easily swayed
we we can be as seemingly sovereign
beings
we presume that we have our own agency
and i'm in control and i define my own
destiny
and you realize that the vast majority
of what you do you don't even understand
how your genes are manipulating your
emotions
let alone when you then start to scale
that
across a 50 person workplace and a
10 person family and the interactions
between all of them and
social media with a couple of billion
people on it
consuming the world's news in real time
24 hours a day
right it doesn't surprise me that we're
in a mess in 2020 it really doesn't
and i my
fear which i wish usually i'm able to
kind of assuage things because i believe
i get myself set on a particular idea
and then i
realize i've talked myself into it
rather than needing to be talked out of
it but that was my
my question about is this on an upward
trajectory and
my fears about the control problem for
agi
and existential crisis and risk and
stuff like that
is that like this this could be the
great filter
as robin hansen puts it this could be
the thing that stops us from actualizing
our potential as a civilization
and dear lord if if the thing that
kept us together below dumbar's number
when we were living valley to valley
and trying not to get the pathogen from
the tribe next to us
is the thing that stops us from
colonizing the galaxy
we didn't deserve to do it
yeah you know i've been surprised that
during this recent election cycle we
didn't see more
deep fakes which i think are just gonna
be it's gonna just completely erode our
ability to tell
what's real you know like you can have a
perfect deep fake of
any political candidate you want to just
like clearly sitting down there talking
to someone who's
not really there and you can just make a
perfect
fake like how much would that just
destroy i mean like the access hollywood
thing that people thought was going to
take
trump down you know the whole in the uh
was it a motor home or something or a
bus
in the future they could we could they
could make those videos just from
scratch
you know just with actors and just deep
fake it
all the way i mean i'm i'm shocked we
didn't see them now because i've seen
some deep fakes that are
scary good now and they're a lot better
than they were even just a year ago
so i i think yeah
everything is kind of pointing to the
trajectory of
we're not going to have the ability to
know what's true
anymore with any high degree of
confidence and actually
that kind of relates to the control
problem for agi right that what you want
to do
is you want to have the
particular goals aligned before you give
the system the power to enact them
you need to ensure that you have the
foundational source code of the
direction that that's moving incorrect
before it has the ability to move at a
speed that
occurs to happen and in a weird way
we have gone backward with a lot of
the values and the virtues that had
taken a couple of thousand years to
develop
and had arrived at the society that kind
of understood how
things were supposed to work and that
now being undone
whilst at the same time the speed at
which you can
undo it and promulgate these new
messages
whether that be through technology
communication stuff like that
but it's like it's like going backwards
it's like going backwards at twice the
speed
somehow like going backwards and up in
the air at the same time
and just getting dropped out of an
airplane like the uh
the deep fake thing is is absolutely
crazy
and you're totally right it doesn't
surprise me that's the case another
thing that i learned
a while ago was the difference in uh
suggestiveness that people have from vr
have you seen this so i don't think so
um
there's a basically an upper bound on
the level of change that can occur to
your belief system
when you're consuming content through a
particular type of medium let's say it's
two-dimensional on your phone with audio
and video
but then when you strap a vr headset
onto yourself
they were able to show people i think
the study was done on
it was to do with paper to do with the
trees that were cut down for paper
and it had some unbelievable multiplier
larger impact on how people
related to their paper usage and their
the way that they felt about the
environment
mostly because it was such a more
immersive
absorption mechanism i suppose and
yeah [ __ ] man like i i don't i i don't
know what we need to do because it's
like technology is usually what we would
claim would be the solution to all of
our problems in situations like this
let's get back to what truth is let's
use technology to
help enable us but it actually seems
like technology is the delivery
mechanism
it's the needle through which the the
virus is coming
yeah i mean it's this the tool that
ultimately needs to have
as you mentioned like the good inputs to
actually have it result in
good outcomes so yeah you can you can
use it
for any end that you want to want to
want to enact you know
there's a lot of people that are
probably wishing to bring the whole
thing down so
yeah how apocalyptic what an apocalyptic
way to finish a podcast but dude you
know i i really do think that it's
important that we understand
this people can only arm themselves with
correct um knowledge of exactly how
these
messages are being promulgated and no
matter what particular stance you have i
think that being able to talk it's a try
to say it now you know
everybody's shouting and no one's
listening but
it's trite because it's so obvious
um but yeah man what's coming up for
quillette let's
leave the the listeners on a brighter
note what have you guys got coming up at
quillette soon that's going to be cool
you know that there's certain things i
can't talk about too much
commercial commercial confidentiality
doing this again
i will say that there is a a book that's
going to be announced
very very soon um
that's all i'm going to say because i
don't want you get angry
cliffhanging sod colleen all right so if
people want to check you out at swipe
right on twitter where else can they go
uh i have an instagram that's uh swipe
right fitness and that's
right is it my last name w-r-i-g-h-t
uh yeah so i do have a whole fitness
thing i do as well
uh i'm gonna try to do a little bit more
too of that
i didn't know that was you so i was
gonna tag you earlier on today and i was
like there's no way
there's no way that colin's got swipe
right fitness when he's got swipe right
on his
on his normal twitter i was like that
can't be him i won't bother tagging him
so but it is
yeah i was trying to get swipe right but
someone someone took it but they haven't
used that account in
years and they won't respond to my
messages to try to take it from
themselves the worst
kind of human the worst kind of human
look dude thank you so much
everything that we've spoken about will
be linked below i'll also put the
main coletta article that you sent me
earlier on in case
people want to check that out so go
never read below colin thank you man i
appreciate you
been awesome thank you so much
you